peut-être depuis vendredi les
revendications n'ont pas changé
manque d'équipement manque de moyens
financiers des demandes jusque là
restées lettre morte
la mort et c'est pas normal en fait pour
voir ma fille ni au vote
il ya plus à dimanche et c'est pas
normal qu'on les ait des examens finaux
plus bas les masses et tous ceux et
celles qui vont passer de milliers ccf
le papa le passé donc tout cela c'est
contradictoire avec l'enseignement
confessionnel
mon défi non c'est beaucoup d'heures est
le premier moteur de l'étoile fc passé
par troyes s'est pas adapté pour venir
donc voilà ya beaucoup ya beaucoup de
difficultés nous avons décidé de nous
mobiliser au pouvoir montre qu'un petit
peu au peuple ce qui se passe dans les
lycées et là nous avons besoin d'eux
écoute de tout le monde
les élèves du lycée professionnel
agricole du robert soutenus par leurs
professeurs
nous sommes dans le besoin nous n'avons
pas les moyens
les élèves je suis prof de génial 21 et
je ne peux pas faire de tp avec mes
élèves
j'interviens aussi sur la case de 3e
prépa pro et je ne peux pas s'adapter je
ne peux pas faire deux sorties
pédagogiques s'est simplement dit aux
personnes concernées de nous trouver des
moyens pour obliger à travailler les
élèves parce que c'est ça notre objectif
rien qu'on puisse travailler avoir des
moyens voire du financement pour qu'il
va décoller dans souffrance non
l'établissement accueille 250 élèves et
propose quatre filières de formation
chaque année la collectivité
territoriale de martin est plus verte
une dotation de fonctionnement global
d'environ 320 milles euros auxquels il
faut ajouter près de 95 mille euros de
crédits d'équipement
un budget que tous aimeraient bien
va augmenter
[Applaudissements]